[Música]
cuál es el sentido de la vida cuál es
nuestro propósito en este mundo porque
estamos todos aquí en este planeta creo
que muchos de ustedes al igual que yo en
algún momento de nuestras vidas nos
hicimos de este tipo de preguntas pero
por qué me las dice yo pues bueno todo
se remonta a mi niñez cuando tenía
aproximadamente 5 años descubrí que me
gustaba mucho jugar al fútbol y me dije
a mí mismo pues quiero llegar a ser un
futbolista profesional quede campeón del
colegio muchas veces y tuve la
oportunidad de representar a mi
provincia en varias ocasiones entonces
creo que el camino que había tomado pues
era el correcto a pesar de todo esto me
di cuenta que no
es necesario solamente ser muy buen
jugador sino que también debes cumplir
con ciertas características físicas los
cuales pues yo no poseía a pesar de esto
y esto no fue el final de todo ya que
creo que todos tuvimos algún sueño o
algún objetivo alguna meta que no
pudimos cumplir pero que tomamos otro
camino es importante
entendamos que si las cosas no pasan no
son por algo sino para algo mejor
y ahora
qué había pasado si mi sueño de
convertirme en una persona famosa de
ganar mucho dinero o de viajar por el
mundo pues prácticamente se había
desvanecido la verdad es que me sentí un
poco desorientado
y lo dejé de lado recuerdo que cuando
entré a la universidad fue un choque de
expectativas y porque porque yo creía
que me iba a topar algo así tipo
american para yo creo que todos todos
hemos visto algunas de estas películas
con fiestas muy locas con chicas con
mucho alcohol y llosa descontrol total
pero la verdad es que la universidad el
ámbito social y académico fue muy
tranquilo
bueno no me desmotiva y dije vamos a
disfrutar de esta nueva etapa en mi vida
pero creo que me tomé muy a pecho lo de
disfrutar y por qué
porque salí casi todos los fines de
semana durante casi un año y qué pasó en
este periodo de tiempo pues la verdad
creo que me aburrí o me saturé porque
decía creo que la vida es más que salir
cada fin de semana de fiesta a beber
alcohol conocer chicas y así
sucesivamente cada fin de semana
obviamente no estoy criticando a las
personas que hacen eso pero yo quería
hacer algo distinto y me di cuenta de
algo de algo muy importante y es que
porque todos escapamos de nuestras vidas
porque odiamos tanto los lunes y
queremos que llegue el viernes de ciudad
por fin bien les voy a poder salir y
todo entonces me doy cuenta de que creo
que todos o la mayoría escapamos un poco
de nuestras vidas porque porque tal vez
no nos gusta nos cansa o nos de estrés y
viene a mí o un mágico descubrimiento
algo que saben todos en verdad pero que
muy pocos vivimos conscientes de esto y
saben que es pues que te vas a morir que
todos nos vamos a morir que sólo se vive
una vez y ustedes mira hay este mango y
meto el agua tibia no la verdad es que
me doy cuenta que muchas personas llevan
vidas que no les gusta no hacen cosas
con pasión y es ahí donde nace mi loca
idea de reflexionar
tratar de hacer de este mundo un lugar
mejor y empezar a vivir las cosas que te
dan la vida con con más pasión
obviamente no les digo que todas las
cosas en la vida vas a hacer la
compasión por ejemplo me levanto con
pasión hago deberes con pasión la
televisión compasión voy al baño con
pasión o sea la verdad es que las cosas
no son así pero hay momentos en la vida
que tú dices qué bueno estar vivo en
verdad es es un regalo esos momentos que
tiene harta en ese cine entiendo eso es
a lo que yo me refiero y ahora pero
ustedes me dirán
cómo encontrar el sentido de nuestra
vida pues fácil con tres pilares
fundamentales hizo el primero descubre
todo o desarrolla alguno de tus talentos
desarrolla lo explotarlo compártelo
y ponlo al servicio de los demás el
segundo pilar es vive como si fueras a
morir entre 5 o 10 años porque este
lapso de tiempo porque creo que en este
tiempo se puede crear algo trascendental
el punto el pilar número 3 y no menos
importante que es autoestima total
porque debe ser la primera persona que
crea en sus tal vez ideas un poco locas
y les quiero preguntar algo a todos yo
no sé si se acuerdan que hace dos días
murió un escritor de cómics muy famoso
tal vez saben cómo se llamaba
y yo me pongo a pensar y digo que le
dirían los papás de stanley cuando él
quería hacer cómics
hijito cómo es que te quieres poner a
estar dibujando cosas así mejor consigue
un trabajo normal
como todos pero la historia habla por sí
sola ustedes saben lo que él llegó a
hacer y todo el legado
y ahora pero que es nuestro don
es simple y sencillamente es eso que te
gusta hacer eso que te apasiona o algo
les pongo más fácil esto cierto gusto o
fascinación por alguna actividad o
alguna profesión y algo muy importante
en esto del don es que debes ponerlo al
servicio de los demás
pero como descubrimos mí o algunas
personas pueden decirme que es muy fácil
darme cuenta que soy buena pero para las
que no es tan fácil pues les doy tres
consejos haz una lista de las cosas que
tú haces con facilidad cuando algo
hacemos con facilidad nos gusta la
mayoría de veces si no te gusta pues
todo no va por ahí después que cosas tú
admiras en los demás naturalmente cuando
nos gusta algo de otra persona nos
imaginamos haciendo eso y finalmente
pregunta a las personas qué es lo bueno
y lo malo que viene en ti lo bueno para
que sepas cuáles son tus fortalezas y lo
malo para que trabajes en tus
debilidades y te des cuenta en qué cosas
debes mejorar
y de qué nos serviría
y encontrar
el sentido a nuestra vida pues hay un
dato importante según el afamado
empresario inversionista robert kiyosaki
quien es el escritor del libro padre
rico padre pobre tal vez alguien debió
haber leído este libro nos dice que el
97% de las personas luchan y trabaja
solamente por el 3 por ciento de dinero
que hay en el mundo y el otro porcentaje
es solamente el 3 por ciento de personas
en el mundo lucha y trabaja por el 97%
de dinero que hay en el mundo esta cifra
no es tan descabellada porque porque en
el mundo existen muy pocos millonarios y
pues el otro 97% que somos todos
nosotros tenemos un salario más o menos
en los mismos rangos obviamente entre
altos y bajos pero la diferencia no es
tan y yo les pregunto a todos como
esperan triunfar
en un mundo donde todo ya está inventado
donde es muy difícil crear cosas nuevas
y prácticamente todo lo encuentras en
internet pues le respondo hacemos lo
mismo que el 97% de las personas y es
ahí donde entra tu talento que más
ofrece es al mundo que más le das un
plus a las cosas que haces
por mencionarles un ejemplo todo el
mundo te dice que para triunfar debes de
estudiar y lo digo que no lo hagan pero
la mayoría de personas va a la
universidad después obtiene una maestría
después de un doctorado y sé que ahora
hasta ahí el postdoctorado pero va a
llegar un punto en nuestras vidas donde
todos tengamos el mismo nivel de
estudios y yo les digo pues porque
deberían contratarte a ti oa mí y no a
otra persona
si tenemos todos lo mismo así que
desarrollen su don
messi cristiano ronaldo son dos ejemplos
claros de personas que han desarrollado
su don obviamente en el deporte y son
dos de los deportistas
mejores pagados a nivel mundial y no les
doy un ejemplo
bueno pues más claro y no sólo de gente
externa conmigo si yo no me hubiera
hecho este tipo de preguntas o
planteamientos y desarrollar tal vez un
talento que es hablar así en público y
no tener pánico escénico pues no estaría
aquí no hubiera conocido excelentes
personas
así que si ustedes creen que mi idea es
muy loca y que hay es que las cosas no
se pueden alcanzar
deben saber que no todo en la vida a
querer es poder son besos no es lo que
estoy hablando pero si puedes alcanzar
muchas cosas si tú
plantea su creación un camino
bien estructurado los grandes avances de
la ciencia y de la tecnología se han
dado gracias a personas que han tenido
la oportunidad de cuestionarse y
proponer mejores alternativas a las
personas y mejorar la vida de todos así
que finalmente yo les digo a todos
salgan y descubran su don para que vivan
una vida con pasión gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]